today I'm gonna explain the 8 most
underrated quirks in might hear academia
now for those of you who are unsure an
underrated quirk is one that people
generally don't appreciate just how
powerful or useful it actually is so
I'll go through the list and then at the
end of it I'll do my ranking of the
three best and you guys can let me know
which you consider to be the three best
as well but the actual list of these
eight quirks itself will not be listed
in order and with that said let's get
into the video okay so starting at
eighth place we have the quirk known as
earth flow which is possessed by the pro
hero pixie Bob now we first saw this
quirk during the Forrest training arc in
season three and at its full potential
no one can deny that this is one of the
best quirks around in fact it was so
good the horikoshi decided to
immediately have her taken out by
surprise before she had a chance to use
it against the villains this guy knew
what he was doing so earth flow allows
the user to manipulate the ground in
whatever way they choose as long as they
make contact with it as we saw pixie bob
can create avalanches at will as well as
having this pretty interesting second
ability which enables her to conjure up
these demons made from the soil and she
can control them from a distance and
while they do look pretty menacing class
1-a was able to take them out pretty
easily even Minetta sticky balls were
able to get in on the action however
putting that aside the ability to alter
the ground in this way is very similar
to the way that oppa who applied his
power and in theory pixie bob is also
able to create spikes in the same way
that he did and also to rearrange the
terrain and surrounding area in much the
same way that he did as well and like I
said that's why she was taken out so
quickly once the villains attacked
because if she was activeness she
could've just opened up the earth and
buried these guys alive or maybe just
cause the ground underneath them to send
them flying into the sky kind of like
this now in the ultra analysis book her
power and technique is rated a very
impressive five out of six but in terms
of the recognition that she gets I
personally feel that we as fans do not
appreciate her level of power and this
awesome quirk hopefully now she gets a
bit more respect on her name now next up
on the list we have a tie at seventh
place because I consider both these
powers to be two sides of the same coin
so firstly we have the quirk known as
impact recoil which was stolen by
all-4-one
because this guy just has so many quirks
and he often combines
it becomes very easy to forget that he
has some really great individual
abilities now this quirk is arguably one
of the best powers he's gained as it
reverses the impact of any physical
force that he takes as an example when
he was fighting all my he got hit with
the classic Detroit smash or rather he
made gran torino get hit with it and
once he activated this quirk the
strength of that attack was then
redirected back onto all my this meant
that his own attack was used against him
impact recall is so great because it
almost acts as a deterrent to getting
attacked sort of like the real-life
concept of mutually assured destruction
where countries that have nuclear
weapons typically don't nuke each other
as they know the same thing will happen
back to them
however admittedly it does have a few
drawbacks as we saw during the battle at
Kamino impact recall takes a second to
activate which means that the person
getting hit will still feel their pain
and the initial impact before the quirk
kicks in but despite that I still
consider it to be pretty fantastic and
it deserves a little bit of spotlight
here and there now the reason I tied it
for seventh place is because there's
another quirk which is almost like the
inverse of this and the power I'm
referring to is possessed by a class 1b
student near and Jackie so rather than
reversing the impacts of something like
all for once quirk nearin Gehrke's quirk
enables him to cause a second impact
that is significantly stronger than the
first and what makes this quirk so
amazing is that he can activate it from
a distance so for example let's just say
that the impact we're talking about here
is you dropping your phone on the ground
this guy could then use his quirk to
remotely create a second impact that
would probably shatter your phone into a
million pieces
what a dick this ability to remotely
create a second impact is pretty damn
impressive and no offense to nearing
Gehrke but it is basically the ultimate
psychic quirk still though underrated
now moving on to sixth place we have the
quirk known as compress which is
obviously possessed by none other than
mr. compress very creative naming
process there those of you who follow me
on Twitter might have seen that I said
that mr. compress is my favorite league
of allah now not only is his power
criminally underrated but you also can't
deny that he puts on a good show a fight
between these two is honestly what I
need to see before the series ends but
talking about his quirk specifically
compris allows him to shrink down
anything into a marble whether that be a
living person or a part of a living
person or a soon-to-be dead person or
you know just cars and stuff
once he's compressed something the
weight of that thing that he's
compressed is significantly reduced
meaning Li can transport heavy objects
without much trouble at all why he
hasn't started a house moving service I
have no idea we seen compress use disk
work in a variety of ways and when it's
combined with his Illusionist nature
he's able to sneak up on people and
capture them by surprise the fight is
literally over the second he turns
someone into a marble because the
trapped person has no way of escaping I
mean just look at back ago when he was
trapped inside this thing absolutely
raging compris himself is insanely
clever in the way that he uses this for
example like when he made dummy marbles
full of Totoro keys ice and the fact
that it allows you to reduce the weight
of heavy items that's almost like a
quirk in itself to be honest sadly
though mr. converses use of disability
has been somewhat held back after
overhaul blow up his arm so for the time
being it's just his right arm that is
underrated at fifth place we have the
quirk known as hell flame which is
possessed by the new number one hero
endeavor now I know what you're thinking
how could the character currently ranked
number one in the hero rankings be
underrated as I kind of implied in the
intro an underrated quote doesn't have
to be one that people think is bad but
rather it can be something that we just
don't appreciate how strong it really is
so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give you
a few examples of how endeavor has used
this quirk that hasn't yet been seen in
the anime but I won't give away any plot
twists or plot spoilers that said if you
really don't want to know skip to the
timestamp on screen if you want to go to
the next character but for those of you
who want to hear about the greatness
that is hell flame let's get into it so
first things first there was a moment in
the manga that genuinely made me sit
back and like rub my eyes in disbelief
if you've not read it this is gonna be
insane to hear and never use this quirk
to incinerate the top half of a
skyscraper in the words of the other
heroes who witnessed it that is a
god-like move how the hell do you burn
the top half of one of those things like
how did you burn it to dust in an
instant and on top of that his quack
essentially gives him the power of
flight as we see in this panel where he
shoots off into the sky like Johnny
Storm give this man and his quark the
respect that he deserves
prominence bond move is so strong that
it is able to defeat villains who have
super regeneration think about how
powerful you need to be to destroy
something that would ordinarily just
regenerate in a few seconds I could go
on as endeavour has a lot of different
techniques that he showed us including
that moment in the anime where his
flames went blue for a split second but
I'll just summarize it by saying this
he'll flame was definitely a quirk that
I myself underestimated so this video
right here this is my apology to
endeavour I'm actually sorry man please
do not kill me now at fourth place we
have the quirk known as mushroom which
is held by Class B student Kinoko she
can create these spores of fungus from
our body which then quickly grow into
full-sized mushrooms once they make
contact with a solid surface this allows
her to completely change the environment
in an instant but the slight drawback is
that if it's not a humid environment the
spores don't travel very well hence why
she walks around with two humidifiers
that are definitely not shaped like
pistols now I'm gonna be honest with you
guys here this is probably the worst
quirk on this list but I did include it
because there was one thing that she's
able to do with this quirk that made a
lasting impression on me I won't go into
any spoilers on who she did this to but
using her mushroom quirk she's able to
choose to create mushrooms inside her
opponents throat and lungs so that means
that by using this technique you can
literally suffocate your opponent to
death not implying that she would do
that or anything I mean look at her but
joking aside you can definitely tell she
wants to a quirk that has the potential
to suffocate people in a way that 99% of
characters will not be able to fight
against to me that's a winning quirk in
my book or at least one that we should
acknowledge and for that reason that is
why Conoco has a place on this list
before we move on to third place don't
forget to sub to the channel if you
haven't already as I'm trying to reach
50,000 subscribers by the end of March
thanks guys now in 3rd we have the quirk
known as object identification now the
name of this one is pretty
self-explanatory but it allows the user
to garganta fie any object that they
touch we saw this demonstrated by a
student from sage in high school I think
I said that right
and using this ability this guy was able
to turn a handful of nuts and bolts into
weapons of mass destruction and this my
friends is the reason I love this quirk
ordinary items become things that can
crush villains or reshape your
environment imagine
trap somewhere right let's just say for
example that you're trapped inside a
cave now all you would need is like a
bunch of coins or something and if you
trucked it at the wall and garganta
fight it you'd be out of that cave in
two seconds well that's if the falling
rocks don't kill you I guess which
brings us to the main downside of this
quirk which is that it's super easy to
cause unintended destruction with
something like this which is kind of a
problem that mountain lady has also
experienced still though in my opinion
this power deserves way more recognition
and although it might cause a lot of
damage it would still be good for taking
out very powerful villains now next up
we have Ned Gerace quirk which is called
wave motion now not only is notorious
quirk underrated but out of all the big
three members Ned jury has had by far
the least amount of spotlight come on
our Akashi we need an origin story you
you owe us that much at least at its
most basic form wave motion allows her
to convert her stamina into these
massive shock waves now these shock
waves can't be released in a straight
line and instead they come out as a
spiral and this twisting motion is
naturally slower than quarks that just
shoot things out in a straight line but
as we've seen the jury has reached such
a level of power where speed isn't even
an issue anymore
the fact that they twist like this also
ties into our first name which literally
means to twist because her quirk drains
her energy to be used she has to build
up an incredible amount of stamina to
avoid the negative side-effects her
stamina is so great that she was able to
carry on for 20 minutes after being
drained by Katsucon maze stamina
stealing quark weight motion isn't just
limited to our hands either as we see
that she creates these little shock
waves out of the soles of her feet which
gives her the proportion she needs to
fly or just to hover casually in the air
even the tiny waves are capable of
holding up an entire human being guys so
yeah these waves are not to be played
with but with all that said we finally
got into the last character on this list
and after I tell you who this is we're
gonna then do a ranking of the top three
so the last quirk of this list is double
which is a quirk possessed by twice
double allows him to create an exact
copy of anything whether it's a living
person or an inanimate object the copies
he makes of living people are capable of
their own independent thought and he
can't actually control them in order to
duplicate something he needs to know the
exact measurements and characteristics
of him and we've seen in the manga B
he's
not been able to copy a certain because
he didn't know exactly what it was made
of now twice can make a maximum of two
copies of one thing at a specific time
and both of these clones are not as
durable as the real thing so for example
if he makes two clones of a person the
first comb would be able to be destroyed
if they suffer damage equal to breaking
a bone and the second clone would be
even weaker than that
that said the comb still possessed the
exact same power as the real versions
which is what makes double one of the
most annoying quirks to ever exist how
many times in the anime and manga and
even the movies have the heroes fought
very very hard against villains managed
to defeat them or capture them only to
find out that they weren't even real you
literally don't know who you're fighting
against until you've won the battle now
twice has the secret move that's only
ever been seen in the manga so before I
mention that skip to the timestamp on
screen if you want to see the quirks
that I ranked in my top three but if you
don't mind the spoilers from the my
villain academia arc then let's get into
it in that arc twice was able to use his
super move called infinite doubles now
infinite doubles allows him to create a
copy of himself and then those clones
because they have his exact power
they're then able to create copies of
themselves who then create copies of
themselves and so on and so on the
process is repeated over and over until
you just have an ocean of twice clones
and the reason this quirks underrated is
because a lot of people do not even know
that he can do this we saw twice copy
himself in the anime and then his clones
went on a rampage and killed each other
hence why he only clones other people
but once he overcame his trauma in the
manga he was able to unlock this
infinite doubles ability and to be
honest with this quirk who would stop
him from taking over the world like if
he made 10 billion twice close who's
gonna stop him who we've reached the end
of this list so with all that said let's
getting to the best three underrated
quirks so the bronze medal goes to
compress due to the large variety of
ways that it can be taken advantage of
and the silver medal goes to hell flame
because of its sheer power and again
we've seen Endeavor uses in a multitude
of different ways that serve a lot of
different goals but my friends the gold
medal the best underrated quote that
exists in my academia is double this is
a quirk that even characters in the show
admit has the power
to take down entire countries also it's
pretty interesting that he's never
replicated all-4-one at least as far as
we know what if the one we saw at camino
was a clone the whole time could you
imagine that this guy is a thorn in the
side of hero society and as long as he's
around the heroes are really up against
it even Hawk said that this guy is the
one we need to watch out for from the
league of villains but let me know in
the comments which ones do you rank in
your top three thanks for watching as
always and I'll be seeing you soon for a
discussion video that I did with one of
my fellow favorite youtubers but until I
upload that peace out